los líderes comunitarios los detectaron
como jóvenes que quizás estaban en ocio
en situación vulnerable que estaban en
búsqueda de trabajar de hacer algo
productivo por su familia y por su
comunidad y tuvieron aquí pues la
posibilidad de llevar a cabo esa
motivación
[Música]
todo
yo me la pasaba en la calle todavía
vagando sin escenas no tenía nada que
hacer
y caracas me convive como decir me
rescato es así lo hacemos la que yo
estaba y me
me importó la albericia y me quedé
encantado con todos los gays con el
estilo de corte peinado todo eso yo
empecé aquí con chile cómo te explico
mira
que no sabía nada absolutamente nada ni
siquiera guerra mágica nada y conchalí
evolucionado en tanto este tema
demasiado y que pero bueno eso es lo que
te dije montar mi propio negocio
ser una barberá profesional
[Música]
toda esta formación se da con la
intención de que estos jóvenes que
muchas veces sufren de exclusión escolar
de dificultades para encontrar trabajo
o provienen del contexto donde hay mucha
violencia puedan encontrar en esta
formación distintas herramientas que le
permitan afrontar sus situaciones y
superarse
[Música]
[Aplausos]